we're joined now by member of
president-elect joe biden's coronavirus
advisory board michael osterholm he's an
epidemiologist
epidemiologist i can say that word and
director of the center for infectious
diseases and research
and policy at the university of
minnesota michael good morning thanks
for coming back
we appreciate you being here again good
morning good morning thank you for
having me
is is president-elect biden's goal to
distribute a hundred million vaccine
doses in his first 100 days
still achievable given how much trouble
we are having
getting this vaccine into people's arms
well i'd call it an aspirational goal
and one i think we must strive for
we know right now that every day we
don't have vaccine in people's arms
people are getting
sick and dying and so i think every uh
effort must be made to do that
and uh you know the team is behind him
in every way they can to help make it a
reality
michael on this broadcast before you you
praise the efforts of operation warp
speed
in getting us a vaccine but you were
very concerned about the last stretch
why are we having so much trouble in
in distributing this vaccine
well anthony as you said i've been very
concerned for some time and actually for
over
many weeks i've been saying this last
mile and this last inch was going to be
a real problem the last mile meaning
getting the vaccine
to the populations that are at highest
risk first of all
long-term care facilities and hospitals
health care centers
right now we have had a real challenge
getting vaccine into long-term care
facilities because the two
private pharmacy companies that had the
contract with the trump administration
to do that have been very slow in
getting it done second of all in the
health care setting
it's been a challenge because many of
these hospitals right now
themselves are overrun with the cases
of covid 19 and it's very hard to be
able to coordinate both getting vaccine
into these
health care workers at the same time
they're working 16-hour shifts day after
day
and but that's coming and it's getting
done and now what we need to do
once we get those two done we need to
then get to the other high-risk
populations
age is clearly a critical one you're
seeing some states right now
they're already targeting those over 75
we'll move next to 65.
if we cover those groups right there we
will start to really have an impact on
the number of serious illnesses
and deaths we saw earlier in this
broadcast uh charlie dagetta from london
reporting on
from a race track where where the
british are putting vaccines in a huge
number of people
do we need to to make that kind of an
effort
we will make that kind of effort uh
first of all state and local health
departments which really are the
air traffic control towers in each state
for moving these vaccines into the right
populations at the right time
really have not been engaged in a way
that they will be
with the new biden effort they have not
yet received support
from the federal government to even roll
out these vaccines
and so in that regard it's been a real
challenge trying to hire vaccinators
the kind of programs where you actually
get people registered efficiently
they know when to go where to go and how
to go to
get their vaccine i think you're going
to see that all changing in the days
ahead
and all i can say is we have to change
it because again
i just in the time that we're doing this
interview think you know
10 to 20 people in this country will
have died from covet
that's what we're up against right now
michael how soon do you expect the
vaccine will be widely available
in this country well we're going to
start seeing it ramp up every day if we
get a third vaccine
which may be approved in the next month
or so
you know by the second into the second
quarter we could have an abundance of
vaccine but then let me just say the
last piece
of that last mile last inch is getting
people convinced they need it
we're still seeing pockets of great
resistance to getting the vaccine
vaccine hesitancy again this
administration has done not done nearly
enough
to help educate people about what these
vaccines are how safe they are what they
can do
and the fact that they can only save
your life but the life of a loved one
all right sure can michael osterhome
thank you so much for being with us
again we appreciate thank you